i don't think any number's too high for
me personally um at the end of the day i
know i sound like a broken record um and
you guys can keep hearing this but as
long as i'm playing here or playing in
nfl uh
as long as i take care of my body
you can take me do the right things my
body's gonna take care of me
so i'm gonna continue to have my team
around me obviously have a great
strength staff here and a great training
staff here but i got to be a pro outside
the facility and whether it's 350
touches whether it's 400 touches whether
it's less touch with next year
whatever
i got to do to help this team win games
and compete for a championship i'm
willing to do
[Music]
let's take one barkley's second overall
pick in the 2018 draft and chris i
remember last year as they were breaking
him in as the season got started and it
was clear that he was special i never
got the feeling that they designed
everything around him like the vikings
did in 2007 when they realized what they
had in adrian peterson if you're going
to use a pick that high on a running
back and he shows he is the real deal
that's the moment where your offense
runs through this guy especially when
you have suspect quarterback play and i
can't help but wonder how much better
the offense would have been last year
and how much better it could be this
year if they just embrace that he is
their adrian peterson and they are going
to run him until the wheels come off
yeah no i hear you yeah you're right
last year they tried to kind of like you
know slowly do it at the start of the
year i didn't want to wear them out it's
their shiny new toy they invested the
second pick in the draft so they're
trying not to kill him in year one but
ultimately i mean he still was second in
football with touches he led the he led
his own team in rushing and receptions
which is insane uh he's really a
phenomenal football player mike you know
i know you've heard me say it i think
he's the best running back in the nfl
already we've talked about the giant
struggles on the offensive line this guy
averaged five yards per carry gosh how
many games did we watch you know eli
check it down to saquon barkley and him
make you know nine people miss on a
seven yard gain when nothing was there
he is a you you said adrian peterson
that's who he is there has not been a
running back in my eyes at least
uh in the nfl the last 15 20 years as
talented as adrian peterson and i think
saquon barkley is the first guy to come
along to where i go oh this guy has a
chance to challenge you know the
greatness of the best running back of
this era because he's so special
and i think that's the obligation if
you're going to use a top 10 pick on a
running back because there are running
backs available every round of the draft
you can find an undrafted guy from time
to time who ends up being a great player
if you're going to use that high draft
pick on a running back you want to use
that running back and i don't think it's
a coincidence
chris that last year the top three guys
by way of touches ezekiel elliott with
381 saquon barclay with 352 and
christian mccaffrey for 326 they were
all top 10 draft picks you have to use
those guys otherwise take someone else
with that top 10 pick and get a running
back later now here's the other side of
the coin though yeah because to the
extent that this workhorse tailback is
making a comeback in the nfl the problem
with that is and i go back to guys like
sean alexander right once you give that
guy his big contract does he begin to
fall off the cliff because you've
overused him early in his career when
you have two or three running backs you
never create this this monster that
needs to be paid because he's the most
popular guy on the team and everybody
has his jersey and everybody has them on
their fantasy football team and it
becomes bigger than the team and by the
time you've paid him he's not the guy
that he was that's the danger these guys
tend to burn bright for a short period
of time and then they start to fizzle
out and that's the question for elliot
mccaffrey and for barkley how long can
they continue at this level yeah no i
think that's a it is you're right i
think you're spot on with that question
and what we've seen from adrian peterson
of course is he's exceeded our
expectations because he's one of the
freakier people we've ever seen we'll
see with ezekiel elliott you know i
worry about it you know with the style
play in which he runs but adrian
peterson ran the same way a lot of car
crashes and damn he's still really good
saquon barkley i'll say this and i think
he's every bit as freaky as an adrian
peterson and keeps himself in shape and
trains hard and does all the right
things like we heard him say the other
thing i like about him just for the
longevity purposes mike we i think we'd
have a hard time finding too many plays
last year where he was in car crash
collisions you know he's got a little
bit of that barry sanders about him and
there is moments in the game where you
watch him and you go oh i wish he would
just smash it up in there for two or
three yards when nothing was there
that's the only knock you can say about
him but the good thing about that knock
is it will add years and miles to his
career because he's not going to be that
sledgehammer that's just going to
senselessly plow up into the middle of
the line of scrimmage all the time when
nothing's there adrian peterson missed
plenty of games throughout his career
because he had that mentality and i
think if you can take the adrian
peterson's skill and weave in that barry
sanders ability innately to avoid
contact or embrace it the right way you
can have a guy who plays 15 16 games a
year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports